Muy buenas tardes para todos aquí desde
el subway este lugar donde convergen
todas las hinchadas y ya estamos viendo
mareadas mareas de hinchas acrobatas que
están pasando acá llegando aquí para
venir unos momentos antes de irse al
estadio ya en la noche hemos visto
también bastantes argentinos también así
que hay un muy buen ambiente aquí en
este lugar los hinchas argentinos que
consideran que van a llegar a esa final
ahora hace un momento hablaba con unos
de ellos me decían que esperan ganar dos
por uno en los 90 reglamentarios sin el
alargue al que nos tiene por lo general
un poco acostumbrados el equipo croata
Esta es la tercera vez que estos dos
equipos se enfrentan en un mundial de
fútbol la última vez fue 2000 a 18 eso
fue en Rusia en la fase de grupos y
habían sido los croatas los que habían
ganado pero ahora estos equipos pues han
evolucionado bastante en estos últimos
años no son los mismos equipos se tienen
mucho respeto lo han dicho en la
conferencia de prensa el día de ayer lo
dijo escalón y que admira mucho además
ese bloque ofensivo y defensivo que
puede llegar a ser Croacia Así que se
espera un gran partido en el estadio
lusái con una enorme hinchada de
Argentina es lo que nos han tenido
acostumbrados a lo largo de todo este
mundial y bueno Argentina que espera
seguir como lo dijo Nicolás tagliafico
en su rueda de prensa el día de ayer
pues es seguir acompañando a Messi para
poder lograr llegar a esa final y
levantar la copa